well it was pretty clear from today's
pmq's that labour wants a clear dividing
line between itself and the government
over how to pay for this very expensive
new freeze on energy prices well we're
joined now by the shadow business
secretary jonathan reynolds thank you
very much for being
with us so what do you want to see
tomorrow from this trust well i do think
and we have had it trailed and there'll
be something to match labour's offer to
freeze bills i mean we've been quite
clear people cannot pay a household
energy bill of four or five thousand
pounds
now there are mixed messages and
different stories coming out from
government but uh what we would like to
see is the existing package of resources
the government's put there mushed with a
windfall tax believe it's legitimate and
fair to take some of that unprecedented
profit for the benefit of the nation as
a whole we'd also have benefit from
lower um inflation put that together and
that's how we would fund a six-month
freeze in energy prices and have support
for business as well that's what we want
to see now there are we don't know what
the package will be um clearly if it is
as one version of the story is that
households will bear all the cost of
that but over a longer period of time i
think that is unfair and that's a drag
on the economy the government will have
to consider and if it's borrowing well
what we've heard so far from
quasi-quattangle is trust is that they
believe they can cut taxes
increase spending and somehow that will
pay for itself i mean that is that's
clearly untrue we know it's untrue from
previous actions of former conservative
governments
it's interesting isn't it because you
obviously want to see
part of it funded through taxation and
you were talking there about you know
liz truster's plan just not making sense
but i guess what they would argue
is that the way uh to growth is through
lower taxes that's what she wants to see
isn't it and i guess if you're talking
about the you know the record
she would also argue i suppose that now
is the time to try something different
to do something new to not go through
the same tax and spend can you see the
argument
i know that's their argument but this is
where the battleground is going to be so
first of all um illustrious has been a
member of every government over the last
12 years she bears some responsibility
for that i think it is interesting that
their own analysis is that that has been
a failure i mean they're very clear on
that i know quasi quartens called that
treasury orthodoxy but for most of
that's conservative orthodoxy so we both
have the same analysis you know things
haven't been as they should be now for
us
the problem is fundamentally there's a
lack of growth lack of productivity in
the british economy low business
investment is a part of that we know
from what george osborne tried that
cutting the headline rate of corporation
tax did not increase business investment
we already tried that we know it to be
true rishi sonic to be fair to him made
this case and was correct in doing so
what we would say is that lack of growth
comes from lack of clear policy lack of
free consistency no industrial strategy
or it's been tried twice and dropped
twice and that's the wrong message to
send to business we don't spend enough
on science in this country our research
and development it is a much smaller
proportion of gdp than any other
developed nation these are the things to
look at and this belief that there's a
magic wand of cutting corporation tax
and you can pay for that as the
chancellor suggested on monday by what
they call supply side reforms that will
make the economy grow i'm afraid that
it's conservative code for cutting
employment rights and environmental
protections it has failed and it's wrong
we'll find out won't we i guess you know
whose argument is right uh in the months
ahead certainly and liz trust also wants
to uh look at energy supply and the
future of energy too and we're expecting
her of course to be
looking at things like more exploration
in the north sea at reuters reporting
this evening that she is poised to
announce more drilling licenses in the
north sea dozens apparently
more licenses for uh exploration in the
north sea
is that a good thing in your view well
we'll have to see the detail because
any transition plan for the uk has
always had gas as part of that at the
same time i understand like you want to
see the detail but but we know that this
is the road of traven travel that this
is what they want to go down she said it
before she wants to see more exploration
in the north sea is that something that
you would support well she'll have to
prove that it's consistent with our
climate change objectives
internationally agreed treaties that we
have signed up to you'll also have to
how do you do that though how do you
because we have a committee on climate
change that has a carbon budget you're
either in favor of exploration than also
you're not well it's a part of the
transition if
what we don't know is is this new
drilling for already uh found oil fields
gas fields or is it new exploration that
the time skills of that will determine
that there's also a suggestion of well i
mean i'm skeptical that that can be done
on a time scale consistent with the net
zero transition and if it's uh if if it
goes it gets so just to be clear if it
goes against the net zero targets then
you would be against
exploration because not only is that a
breach of our commitments by not
sticking to our commitments we raise the
risk the cost of capital for the kind of
investments we need in onshore wind
offshore wind solar new nuclear a
hydrogen industry you know we lose the
jobs of the future as well as breaching
things that we've signed up for and if
it's a return to fracking as we've heard
part of it look the best case scenario
for fracking even if people wanted it
and it's clear they don't with something
like four billion cubic meters in four
or five years time that is in no way
going to compensate for the loss of
russian supply to europe and quite
frankly i don't think even our geology
and environmental standards in this
country that could be done in a way so
it's the wrong answer and some people
would some people would say look uh we
understand of course the how important
the commitment to net zero is we
understand the uh need for investment in
renewables but in a time of energy
supply crisis don't we need to look at
every option on the table including in
the north sea including fracking you can
build a wind farm quicker than you can
get fossil fuels out of the north sea
should we be doing both of those things
well it depends if if she can prove that
is consistent with our net zero
objectives but if she can't not only is
that the wrong thing to do it will risk
the investments that we most need to see
for the long-term future of the country
and i think again you know there's an
element of of to be honest fantasy about
a lot of list dresses plans whether it's
on the economy in tax and spend or on
areas like this now we need the detail
to be fair to them but in terms of what
i've seen in the conservative leadership
contest i think we should be worried
there does seem uh one of the few things
that there is a consensus over is the
need to try and act to at least freeze
or reduce people's bills in the short
term
we also have a crisis in energy supply
is there a risk that by acting to reduce
bills or to keep bills lower than they
would be otherwise we're not
incentivizing people to cut their usage
at a time when it's energy supply that
is the issue i mean are you worried
about blackouts do we need to look about
rationing
i'm not worried by that because first of
all when people say freezing prices at
the current levels there's no incentive
to reduce your own consumption well
let's be clear that we're freezing them
at levels considerably higher so i you
know the incentive is certainly there
for people in my constituency and i
think the nation as a whole if the
government makes the right decisions
there shouldn't be the risk of what you
are saying but you know let's be clear
there hasn't been there's a huge drop
off in home insulation installations
after 2010 david cameron cut the green
crap that that you know reduced the
ambition of their own policy you could
have taken 15 percent you know roughly
out of the demand in terms of natural
gas had those decisions not been made
the bannon onshore wind has been
counterproductive and closing the
storage facility and you know again
another conservative decision really
poor decisions that have increased our
exposure but the government can still
make better decisions now and that's
what they need to do alongside measures
should we be looking at things like
they're looking at in germany like
stopping lighting public monuments or
asking shops to shut their doors well i
think there is a
there is some benefit in a public
education campaign around you know
different ways to reduce consumption an
amazing number of homes in this country
don't even have thermostats and that
could relatively easily be solved but i
would worry by talking about that that
we are only the government can make the
kind of intervention that is required on
a crisis of this scale and there's
always in us all living our lives in a
more efficient way and using scarce
resources as best as possible that's not
an answer to the crisis this requires
real action from government because
that's the scale of the challenge okay
interesting stuff thank you very much
jonathan reynolds